nun aber endlich zu einem wirklich
wichtigen thema herzogin kate hatte vier
mal dasselbe outfit an
peinlich meint die boulevardpresse ich
persönlich find's super genau das
richtige zeichen in dieser bekloppten
modewelt wo eine kollektion nach der
anderen raus geballert wird
immerhin hat deutschland wissen sie
vielleicht gar nicht seit rund einem
monat den sogenannten grünen knopf das
neue fairtrade gütesiegel eingeführt von
entwicklungsminister müller gilt leider
nur in deutschland dabei ist da gehört
eigentlich so ein internationaler typ
[Musik]
kann man immer wieder gucken
gemen
ja also gerd müller ohne frage einer der
besseren minister im kabinett der
integra man aber was kann sein grüner
knopf dieses siegel steht für einen
sozialen und ökologischen
mindeststandards in der textilbranche
leider überwacht es aber nur einen teil
der produktionskette und der garantierte
mindestlohn ist nur der vor ort und von
dem kann man zum beispiel in bangladesch
überhaupt nicht leben außerdem und da
kommen sie jetzt nie drauf die teilnahme
ist freiwillig hätten sie das gedacht
focus teil gerade mal 27 deutsche firmen
machen bis jetzt mit aber die werden
quasi einzeln gelobt ich kaufe lieder
bananen sagen ich habe einen boss am zug
mir gekauft ich habe natürlich auch eine
frau den autor hose trage unterwäsche
von trigema ja
klassischer fall von zu viel information
inzwischen wird ihnen aufgefallen sein
gibt es tatsächlich in deutschland einen
ganzen dschungel aus ferne segeln da
blicken nur die allerwenigsten noch
durch einige dieser siegel
wir sind ok andere sind ein klarer fall
von greenwashing ohne frage haben sich
manche standards in asiatischen
sweatshops verbessert aber nur weil er
jetzt mehr firmen der kläranlage haben
heißt das noch lange nicht dass sie die
auch benutzen
in china heißt es scherzhaft der fluss
trägt schon die trendfarbe der nächsten
saison wenn die fabriken ihre stoffe
gelb färben dann ist der fluss gelb dann
sehe ich bei google earth schon die
trendfarbe von nächster woche wie
praktisch 8000 liter wasser verbraucht
die produktion einer einzigen jeans 9000
liter für einen pullover die herstellung
von kleidung erzeugt mehr co2 als der
gesamte flug und schiffsverkehr zusammen
vorschlag wir fliegen alle weiter aber
nur noch nackt ja oder geht das nicht
wegen dem nachtflugverbot ich weiß es
nicht
und übrigens übrigens dieselben firmen
die sich neuerdings angeblich so viele
sorgen machen über die
produktionsbedingungen zum beispiel in
bangladesch drücken da jedes jahr den
einkaufspreis im vergleich zum 2014
zahlen sie im schnitt 57 dollar pro kilo
kleidung weniger ja weniger fairtrade am
arsch und am ende schicken wir die
ganzen billigklamotten die wir genau
einmal oder so getragen haben dann als
altkleider spende wieder zurück dass
endlosen dabei da passen hier vier leute
gleichzeitig das ist wirklich witzig ich
frage mich immer was ist die leute da
mutig werden ja da kann ich aus
erfahrung berichten nur mit fressen ist
es nicht getan
man darf sich auch nicht bewegen es ist
wirklich ein geht es ja auch alles nicht
lustig und alles totaler wahnsinn jeder
deutsche jeder von uns kauft im schnitt
60 neue kleidungsstücke pro jahr und das
nur die oberbekleidung eingerechnet 60
sicher vor allem jugendliche fünf super
wie billig man bei primark und co
schocken kann warum weil man sie einer
24 stunden youtube gehirnwäsche
unterziehen
ja weil die voll cool sind drei euro
also 15 euro zu teuer findet man auch
die hat nur 190 gekostet und hat auf der
rückseite so ein süßes sagte vor der
seite eigentlich flammen drogen hat 15
euro kostet
[Applaus]
mein reden absolut und erwachsen sind ja
nicht besser
erwachsene sind nicht viel besser unser
eigentliches problem ist die immer
schnellere mode valerie niehaus ist
gelernte fast fashion influenza von ihr
aus warum müssen die neuen kollektionen
der großen ketten immer und immer
schneller schnell ist ein gutes
stichwort wenn man schon für die erste
frage gefüllt eine woche braucht dann
ist man wahrscheinlich auch als
moderator ein bisschen aus der zeit
gefallen selbst fashion heißt eben nicht
lange nachdenken sondern weiter schafft
und fresse halten immer weiter shoppen
früher gab es eine herbst eine winter
eine frühlings und eine sommerkollektion
heute gibt es 52 verschiedene
kollektionen pro jahr
das 52 das ist ja eine kollektion pro
woche sehr gut schweinchen schlau
da kann aber einer kalender lesen und
sie haben natürlich völlig recht das ist
viel zu wenig das jahr hat 365 tage
warum nicht alle zwei stunden neue
kollektion da müssen wir hin fashion
muss noch fester werden wenn da jetzt
und magermodel eingeladen stock akkus
und knochen sagt reinkommt sagte curran
jetzt dann ist das was die trawler an
hat jetzt schon aus der mode als sie das
eben angezogen hat vor zehn minuten da
war das noch hat aber jetzt die das
scheiße aus das ist auch was woanders
concept s deckten sie ist aus dem penner
wirklich ein hat nicht verstehen
also neue mode muss hier raus mit dem
alten plunder
zum glück haben viele deutsche das
verstanden und fangen an nagelneue
klamotten direkt in die kleider tonne zu
schmeißen noch in der originalverpackung
das ist der spirit ich appelliere da
auch wirklich an unsere jungen kunden
ihr würdet der branche so helfen wenn
ihr die sachen einfach direkt nach dem
shoppen wegschmeißt ganz hat ja warum
denn erst nach hause schleppen dann
natürlich auch runter mit den hässlichen
klamotten die er an habt und direkt
zurück zu zara und primark große mode
film verbrennen sogar völlig neue ware
um platz zu schaffen für noch neuere da
werden also sachen um den planeten
geflogen versauen in asien die flüsse
und dann werden sie neu verbrannt das
ist doch krank
nein krank ist wenn gewisse personen des
öffentlichen lebens die eigentlich eine
vorbildfunktion haben 40 mal im jahr die
selbe zerknitterte blauer jacke anziehen
dass es krank und wissen sie was noch
krank ist wenn eine sendung die auch
viele junge menschen gucken seit über
zehn jahren von demselben polyester
anzug mit kassenbrille moderiert wird
das hält mich geradezu an
auch im fernsehen ist eine junge frische
kollektion wo man gerne hinguckt ab und
zu mal ganz schön was
[Applaus]
[Musik]
red
ach so viel applaus im zdf für mich auch
eine neue situation weil hier raus los
geht's
dann komme jetzt mal paar neue junge
team hier mal ansprechen was habt ihr
als nächstes ich warte jetzt war das hat
der deutsche gewerkschaftsbund wird 70
megageil das ist das thema das kann man
ja nicht mal mit dem klavier retten was
soll jetzt gut das hilft nix dann machen
wir das jetzt der dgb hat in dieser
woche in berlin seinen siebzigsten
gefeiert und wahrscheinlich viele kinder
vor dem fernseher heute gar nicht mehr
wissen was so eine gewerkschaft
überhaupt macht hier mal nachhilfe von
onkel dittmeyer schön
wischmeyer sorg buch der bekloppten und
bescheuerten no kids was ist denn ein
dgb also ganz früher da wurden arbeiter
mies bezahlt und behandelt wie heutige
straßenköter also das was ihr heute
praktikum nennt die frühen lohnsklaven
hatten jedoch keine eltern die ihnen
eine wohnung und einen golf gti
finanzieren die armen schweine mussten
sich noch selbst um ihre beschissene
situation kümmern und das nennt sich
seit dem gewerkschafter erfindung wer
viel schafft und wenig rastet bringt
sein leben in gefahr
darum hat er kurz und klug hertrich
stunden sind genug und sonntags vor dem
tatort dann muss partie bei der mode
iran
da rettet ihn ein betriebsrat und wenn
die bosse sich damals nur gestellt haben
dann hat der verdi-chef mit groupies in
mülltüten so lange vor dem werkstor
unter ihr geschlecht getanzt bis es mehr
lohn gab
die haben etwas erreicht mutterschutz
weihnachtsgeld schnitzel dienstag in der
kantine
da kann man ruhig mal gratulieren ihnen
zum siebzigsten geburtstag und alles
gute was immer das bedeutet das weiß
keiner
glückwunsch liebe gewerkschaftlich
organisierte facharbeiter leider
schuften inzwischen neun millionen
niedriglöhner abseits der tarifgebiete
was nützt der regal einräumen bei lidl
das recht auf home office gleichzeitig
haben die ganzen hipster schlüssel auch
keinen bock mehr auf gewerkschaft die
denken nicht im traum daran von ihren
bitcoins etwas für den mumifizierten
bergmann score abzuzweigen
diese agentur fuzzis stellt sich doch
ganz andere fragen wo es der lakers
shatner wo ist das denn so passiert es
denn wo ist der murger wo ist hier
fashion goes muss die große architektur
das muss doch weitergehen wo sind die
magazine wo ist die inspiration wo es
auch gemeint reality wo ist das alles wo
ist die optische brillen das ist alles
so eine konfessionen und wer ist im bus
so leute die das interessiert übrigens
auch der naseweise start ab juli gönnt
sich gern sein sabbatical weiß aber gar
nicht mehr dass er das den uncoolen
gewerkschaften zu verdanken hat mega
viel so viel für heute und in der
nächsten folge
bei unserer kleinen sozialen träumerei
porträtieren wir dann den neuen
thüringer außenminister adolf hocke bis
das buch der bekloppten und besteuert
[Applaus]
ja richtig gesehen ich bin zurück da
braucht er gar nicht so enttäuscht zu
gucken hayward wird lässt sich
entschuldigen er muss noch eine neue
nummer für den fernsehgarten vorbereitet
und zum guten schluss noch ein neuer
verrückter trend aus berlin politiker
interviewen sich gegenseitig der
fraktionschef der cdu durfte zum
beispiel gerade seine kanzlerin
interviewen bizarres gespräch und die
erste folge unserer neuen rubrik das von
uns nur minimal bearbeitete interview
der woche frau bundeskanzlerin liebe
angela schön dass wir heute das
interview führen könnt die bereits da
bin ich auch sehr dankbar dafür wollen
wir gleich einsteigen erste begegnung
mit helmut kohl ist sie dir noch vor
augen
ich war wie schon oft gesagt habe an dem
abend in der sauna gewesen
wie ist da der prozess gewähren das
interessant ich habe ihn anfangs ein
bisschen von ferne gesehen hatte man
nicht angst weil es war eine mischung
aus angst und mut vielen dank michael
beschreibt auf facebook wilke du bist
der letzte arsch nur große fresse ich
möchte ich mal sehen wenn es hart auf
hart kommt dann schaust du dir in die
hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt man
trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zweiter oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren